[Music]
is awesome
sure we're living in the wireless age
but I'm betting they spend a lot of time
like this tethered to a wall
I'm also betting if you're watching this
video right now on your phone you're
slightly freaking out about what it's
doing to your battery life but I don't
actually freak out anymore at least not
on days that I remember to put a battery
cover on my phone
often called mo fees because of the
first company to make these these don't
only double the size earphone they
double your battery life to over the
last week I've been testing ten of these
cases it turns out you can spend less
money and get more power by buying a
competitor to low fee mo fee does have a
new model out this week though it's
called the space pack it has a smaller
battery than the other Mophie cases but
also has 32 gigabytes of storage to add
more space to your phone but the 150
dollar case could only bring my dead
phone up to 82% the 120 dollar Mophie
Juice Pack has a bigger battery it only
got a dead iPhone up to 85% that's got
another case maker Len Marv laughing in
the corner the $90 Len marmer ideon case
for the iPhone charged a dead phone all
the way up to a hundred percent I also
like the hundred dollar boost case
better than the movi it's stylish you
can swap the battery out for a little
wallet on the back and to charge my dead
phone up to 95 percent all of those
cases cost north of $90 but I actually
bought this one on Amazon for wait for
it $15
it has the same size battery as the
boost case but it charged my dead phone
up to a hundred percent though at a
slower rate sure this kickstand will
probably break off but I did mention
it's $15 right it's unclear who actually
makes this case there are tons of them
listed on Amazon under different names
and I don't know if it's gone through
the proper third-party testing that said
my wonderful editor has used one
regularly for the last several months
with no problems in general Android
users aren't as lucky when it comes to
getting battery phone cases there's just
too many Android phone models but I did
test a number of them for the galaxy s4
mo fees case charged a dead Galaxy s4 up
to 68 percent the power skins spare only
got it up to 41 percent and then the
incipio off-grid had the best at 88%
then there's Len Mars halo s4 which puts
the second battery inside the back of
the galaxy s4 it doesn't charge the
original battery but instead adds a full
extra charge the downside is that that
one's hard to put on and you might as
well be walking around with a generator
strapped to your face okay not that bad
a comeback so what did we learn sitting
here today well first that the floor is
very very dirty but more importantly
that these cases are not all created
equal and paying more money doesn't
necessarily mean better performance Len
Mar makes my top choice for the iPhone
and Galaxy s4 the $15 Amazon case is a
great deal but the fact that we don't
know where it comes from is a little bit
worrisome still if you find yourself in
these situations pretty often these
cases are exactly what you need to truly
go wireless